and I think this is because we're
genetically predisposed to pay more
attention to bad things bad is stronger
than good because the bad things could
be a threat to our survival our
hunter-gatherers forefathers who were a
bit more worried [ __ ] didn't relax who
looked anxiously towards the horizon
whether there might be predators or new
storms they probably survived more often
than others so they passed on their
genes to us but also their stress
hormones and their attention to all the
bad things that could go wrong in the
world now add to this another factor the
fact that we are by nature nostalgic we
tend to think that the good old days
were in another era a previous area in
our childhood or even before this even
before that these are some scenes from a
brilliant French movie in 1959 labelled
de meat about a man who goes back in
time to better hear the good old days
where everything was wonderful but then
he's there and he thinks it's pretty
good but then he meets an old man who
tells him oh you should have been there
when I was young life was much better
and then he travels back in time to that
era and it's it's ok a bit boring but
here but no man tells him oh no you
should have been with in that era when I
grew up that was the good old days and
he travels back in that time as well and
it goes to prove that nostalgia is
always there as a cultural historian
after herman put it virtually every
culture past the present has been that
men and women are not up to the
standards of their parents and forebears
and you might if you haven't seen this
film you might recognise the intrigue
from Woody Allen's Midnight in Paris
where he used the same kind of story to
to show us that we always think and
everybody has always thought that the
good old days were days past and
interestingly when I ask people about
those good old days when were they if
this is not the golden era when was
society as at its most harm
ammonia's and and they most often happen
to mention the era when they grew up
people of my generation say it's the
1980s the baby boom generation often say
it's the 1950s and I one hypothesis I've
got is that this present outburst of
nostalgia is a result of the baby boom
generation retiring and thinking back to
the good old days in the 1950s where
life wasn't that great after all where
AM old age meant that you were poor
where we had still Jim Crow laws and
racial segregation in the United States
where we had the threat of immediate
nuclear annihilation but we know that we
solve those problems we know that we got
through those bad old days so now we can
think back to them as the nice era when
we grew up when things were exciting
because we were young and the future was
full of promise and at the same time we
felt fairly secure because our parents
were burdened with all the difficult
decisions they paid the bill and they
were worried about all the things that
could happen to their kids now as we
grow up as we become parents we begin to
think that this is much more difficult
nowadays it used to be much simpler and
this is what author Herrmann thought as
well that often we confuse a certain
shift a change in ourselves taking on
new responsibilities perhaps some
physical decay and we confuse that with
the world and think that this goes on
everywhere it's not us it's the world so
if we have that genetic programming
where we pay more attention to
everything bad that happens or could
happen in the future and we're also
nostalgic so we think that the good old
days are behind us and you add another
factor a new factor global media global
24 hours a day media that looks at
everything around the world
then we have more bad things to take
into consideration because even though
homicide rates decline there's always a
serial murderer on the loose somewhere
even though we have fewer international
wars there's always a war going on
somewhere and then those bad things will
always top the new cycle even though the
risk of being killed in a natural
disaster has declined by almost 99
percent over the last 100 years there
are always people dying in a natural
disaster and then that will top the new
cycle everywhere and then we get the
impression that this is the everyday
occurrence for most people around the
world and add to that social media
Twitter Facebook and Instagram and all
those places where even anyone could can
add their particular perspective on the
world and what do you share with people
yourself on those platforms
well most it happens that we share of
some good news but most often it's
something horrific something dramatic
something shocking human suffering is
not new but cell phone cameras are new
and then it means that we can see
anything that goes wrong anywhere in the
world instantaneously we can see it
while it happens before we know whether
people will survive or not and that
triggers our fear it triggers our
fight-or-flight hormones and it makes us
scared about the world what do I share
on social media well often it's some
weirdo that I've never heard of in a
city whose name I cannot even pronounce
who did something stupid then I think I
have to tell people about this stupid
thing and everybody does the same thing
so we wake up in the morning and hear
about all those weirdos all those
bizarre people doing bad things
everywhere and we think that most people
are like that but they're not and that's
why we're sharing it because it is a
strange strange occurrence a bizarre
occurs
so unfortunately whew I think this is
accelerating with the rise of social
media as well
at an accelerating pace we pay attention
to all those bad things and we get the
impression that the world is falling
apart even though all the objective data
proves otherwise and that's dangerous
it's dangerous politically as Donald
Trump put it when he first made clear
his ambitions to run for president of
the United States this country is a
hellhole and we're going down fast end
of quote
morning in America it ain't anymore and
that changes perspectives on the world
if you look at Trump's voters compared
to 50 years ago life in u.s. is worse
yes 75 percent of his voters say but so
does Bernie Sanders voters because it's
the same thing among among the left is
populist they also think that this
country is a Hello partly for different
reasons
it's the inequality it's rising
sea-levels global warming disasters and
so on and and Hillary Clinton says the
same thing only in full sentences
she she tells us that yes you are angry
you should be angry because everything
is awful and only I can make things
right and this is the problem fear is
the health of the state political forces
can always stifle progress they can stop
this creativity they can block the
technology they can block trade if they
like you know the old joke if the
opposite of Pro is con then what is the
opposite of progress yes it's not new
that has always happened and in every
election season we see the same kind of
thing in every election you threaten
people that if the other guy wins the
water taps will run dry the Sun will not
set tomorrow it will not rise tomorrow
but this is new the sense that
everything is already awful in the US
and in Europe and in other places the
world is dangerous it is dangerous and
if it's dangerous
if the world is falling apart you need a
strong man or a strong woman or a
muscular government that sets things
right if a Martian tried from the planet
Mars try to understand what goes on on
planet earth by listening to a speech by
Donald Trump or Bernie Sanders or Jeremy
Corbyn in Britain or marine lepen in
France he would think that everything is
on fire on planet Earth because they
only talk like violence is spiraling out
of control inequality poverty is rising
everywhere everything is dangerous and
if everything is dangerous we have to
protect what little we have and we need
that strong person that big government
that helps us if people left to their
own devices create a lot of progress
well in that case we can have more
freedom we can have open societies and
open economies because we'll see more
progress in the future but if we think
that people left to their own devices
and free to do things and trade and move
if we think that they create chaos chaos
everywhere then we need those those
strongmen who will take care of all of
us in social psychology there's a
discussion about this about an
authoritarian reflex people like
Jonathan hight Karin Stanner has pointed
out that authoritarianism which is kind
of a loaded term but we can say some
kind of statism where you and and some
sort of interest in blocking people's
freedom blocking globalization
controlling people rather than setting
them free
that kind of authoritarianism is not a
stable personality trait it's more like
a predisposition that a lot of people
have and it can be triggered and it
triggers when people get the sense that
their way of life is threatened when
they have the sense that their society
that they're that people like them or
their countries being threatened by
external forces or by chaos that
authoritarian dynamic sets in when
people read fake stories about things
going wrong in society they become more
authoritarian in other spheres in
responding to other questions that are
not related at all to the very thing
that went wrong in that fake story which
means that we all sort of end up in this
protective mode when we think that
things are going wrong if you only see
horror and horrible people if you wake
up and listen to the breaking news
what's your Twitter feed and find out
that there are only weirdoes out there
and they're out to destroy your way of
life you become more authoritarian you
become more status and you begin to vote
for the strong man or for the big
government so I wrote this book to sum
up not out of complacency not as a way
of telling people that look everything
is in order we don't have to bother
about these things anymore let's go home
and have a quiet night I wrote this book
because I'm worried about this progress
because we cannot take it for granted
it didn't happen automatically by itself
it happened because people were given
more freedom to explore to experiment
and to exchange the results of that if
we have political forces in power that
blocks those freedoms those individual
liberties those economic freedoms then
we'll see less freedom less progress in
the future so we have something to fear
and that is fear itself and the risk
that fear will become a self-fulfilling
prophecy and it will be self generating
because if we think there are only
problems out there only stagnation then
will block the reforms the new
technologies the free trade reforms that
should take place to create more
progress and then we'll see more
stagnation and will be even more fearful
in the future and will be even more
difficult to push through the reforms
that we need to make progress
it could happen we can block progress
like that it has happened before it can
definitely happen again it's bad for
mankind but more than that
it's a boring way to spend your life to
stand in the way of other people's
progress so to conclude in the word so
another one of my intellectual heroes
that great thinker captain james t kirk
of the Starship Enterprise in the United
Federation of Planets
only a fool stands in the way of human
progress thank you thank you very much
you're hung but I was hoping to have on
sale and for reasons that I shall have
to apologize so for the rest of my life
it's not out there so sorry Ron and it
makes wonderful wonderful presence both
of them for the upcoming holidays
Ron Bailey is an award-winning science
correspondent for Reason magazine and
reason.com where he writes a weekly
Science and Technology column he was one
of the original optimists out there and
has and has a tremendous pedigree in
terms of promoting ideas that johan is
talking about or was talking about today
bailey is the author of the end of doom
environmental renewal of 21st century
and also of liberation biology a moral
and scientific case for the biotech
revolution from 1987 to 1990 Bailey was
a staff writer for Forbes magazine
covering economic scientific and
business topics
prior to joining reason in 1997 he
produced several weekly national public
television series including think-tank
and techno politics as well as several
other PBS and ABC documentaries
he's also an editor of a number of books
including global warming and other
ecommons
Earth report 2000 or a visiting true
state of the planet and also eco scan
the false prophets of ecological
apocalypse Ron is a member of society of
environmental journalists and the
American Society of bioethics and
humanities with that help me welcome Ron
Bailey progress and its enemies I'm
going to be taking a very unaccustomed
roll here today
basically most people would describe me
and I have been described as a cockeyed
optimist a technical topia and a
libertarian transhumanist and so forth
and I just want to stress that whatever
nostalgia is I suffer from the exact
opposite of whatever that is if I I
don't have future shock I have future
Glee this is what I'm looking forward to
and fortunately johann it's excellent
book which you should all buy just as
soon as you bought mine it completely
makes that case and very strongly and
powerfully does so so what I'm going to
do is go through some of the challenges
at which Johann also discussed but go
into a greater detail of what some of
the enemies we might have to face as the
21st century unfolds and which way do I
push what am I doing wrong so doubt
alright bye
this one yes yeah I realize that's the
Lonnie well alright should I technical
difficulties progress is being made
don't worry it's joining today just one
second give us a moment okay
if you want I can do that too
can you do it off by heart Wow there we
go attack there we go
no should be working
I find this as discriminatory yo.hannes
worked again I was delighted to hear
that Johann was quoting Robert Heinlein
one of my favorite science fiction
authors and a great intellect but as you
can see he's making a very good point
that throughout history poverty is a
normal condition of humanity in fact
hunt showed that it was a chart advances
which permit this norm to be exceeded
here and there now and then are the work
of an extremely small minority
frequently despised often condemned
almost always opposed by all
right-thinking people whenever this tiny
minority is kept from creating or as
sometimes happened it's driven out of
the society the people then slip into
abject poverty this is known as bad luck
Venezuela is suffering from bad luck
right at the moment is an example but to
highlight a bit more of what this is is
is this is how this progress might be
stymied I'd like to refer to a wonderful
book by Northwestern University
economist joel mill Kerr called the
gifts of Athena historical origins of
knowledge and he pointed out that
history shows that technological
progress in a society is by and large
temporary and vulnerable process with
many powerful enemies with a vested
interest in the status quo or an
aversion to change continuously
threatening it
the net result is that changes in
technology the mainspring of economic
progress and most progress period I
would argue have been relative to that
to what we now know human creativity is
capable of in other words people in the
Roman Empire and before we're as smart
as we were but they were stymied and
we'll get into some of the reasons why
they could not use their creativity to
create the world that we live in and
that stasis or change at very slow rates
has been the rule rather than the
exception again the wonderful data that
Johan showed us it is our own age and
and especially the rap the it is it is
our own age and especially the rapid
technological change in the Western
world that has been the historical
aberration so what happens well mo kio
basically points out that what occurs is
that technological progress inevitably
involves losers and losers tend to be
concentrated and find it easy to
organize sooner or later in any society
the progress of technology will grind to
a halt because the forces that used to
support innovation become vested
interests in a purely dialectical
fashion technological progress creates
the very forces that eventually destroy
it I hope that's not true but it is
something we should be concerned about
is that in fact what you find is that
vested interests over time it will be
discussing a bit more of that I get
control of the government and stymie
their computer competition another trend
though that Johann actually describes
brilliantly in his book is the trend in
education around the world but how that
is liberating both boys and girls men
and women across the world unfortunately
there are some societies where this
trend is being blocked and in some cases
reversed and that is a terrible terrible
problem there are two problems with that
one is is that it has an effect on the
choices that women make with regard to
the number of children they would desire
to have and the second one is it also
dramatically reduces the amount of
growth and economic well-being that
people can earn study after study shows
that if women are educated to at least a
secondary level of education they
complete their secondary education their
fertility reduce is reduced by
third to 50% that is going down from the
from basically five or six children in
countries where women are not educated
to two or three children and part of the
trend that we see and I think is a very
beneficial trend we're and I talk about
in my book is the world population is
very likely to top out at around nine
billion people or so and begin falling
during this century largely again
because women will have learned I hope
will be able to become educated and make
choices that they want about their
fertility
in addition educated women participate
more and in the wage the wage economy
and this has huge benefits as well
Mackenzie economic consultancy just did
a study where they where they calculated
that if women were could achieve just
the average level of education around
the world you see in the world today
that the world economy would be would be
an additional twelve billion dollars
richer in 2025 than it is now it would
be an increase of over eleven percent if
men and women had the same level of
education over that period of time there
would be twenty eight billion dollars
more of GDP by 2025 an increase of
twenty eight twenty eight percent in
other words we are foregoing by keeping
women uneducated in those countries that
do so a huge benefit for themselves and
for us all another problem that was
discussed that Johanna is discussing is
the problem of art our art our key that
is the notion that every country should
be self-sufficient that are new a new
mercantilism that unfortunately our two
presidential candidates leading
presidential candidates I will not be
voting for either of them just for the
record are in favor of restricting free
trade and exchange of ideas and
immigration and so forth
and this is a terrible problem if we can
only produce what we have here in this
country we will be denying ourselves the
benefits of what other people in other
countries can produce more cheaply for
us and also the benefits of innovation
and change this is a example of smooth
hauling and what happened
in the 1930s as the Great Depression was
coming on was senator smooth and
representative Holli managed to get a
the trade managed to get the tariffs the
united states raised quite substantially
and the result was is that and over a
two-year period between 1930 and 1932 US
trade with Europe both exports and
imports filled by two-thirds of course
this led to huge job losses that time
within four years after that 24 other
countries had also raised their tariff
barriers and world trade had fallen by
almost two-thirds at that point
basically was a beggar thy neighbor
activity and this is the policy that
some of our leading politicians will his
name start with T and C are recommending
to us this is again a terrible problem
and already we see that foreign direct
investment in the United States is down
by 40 percent from the peak just before
the the the financial crisis and
international trade is growing at its
lowest rate ever have we achieved or
fallen to the nadir of globalization at
is hope not then there's the problem of
cronyism now this you know our taki is a
problem with international trade largely
but this is an internal problem
basically and just a quote from Lloyd
Blankfein who and as the CEO of Goldman
Sachs and 2015 said more intense
regulatory and technology requirements
have raised barriers to entry higher
than any other time in modern history
sadly he wasn't complaining about that
he was explaining that this was great
for his company and for other companies
like his because it made it possible to
that competitors would not be able to
challenge him and his company and that
extra profits could be earned from that
he was pointing that out as an advantage
for himself the problem is is that we
see this all the time with the
accumulating burden of regulations and
so forth the Mercatus Institute to
commit Makeda Center I'm sorry
just issued a study back in June where
they were calculating what what the
regulatory drag on the United States
would be and I highly recommend looking
in a study but basically our economy is
four trillion dollars poorer than it
would otherwise be basically because of
our regulations and most of those
regulations do serve as barriers to
innovation and to competition even more
startling study was done in 2013 by John
Dawson at Appalachian State University
and John cedar at North Carolina State
where they calculated the following that
if you could imagine keeping the
regulatory burden at the level of 1949
what size would the US economy be now it
would be three times larger than it is
now they figure I don't know it seems
that is a particular problem we need to
be worried about and again something
that Johan was highlighting this is well
this is President Putin and President Xi
Jinping of China and I'm calling this
the return of the natural state one of
the better books but actually one of the
best books I read in the last ten years
is by Nobel Prize winning economist
Douglas North and some colleagues of his
called violence and social orders and
what they were trying to get at is the
notion of how did we handle violence and
society and humanity as they were as the
agricultural revolution took off hit
upon one solution which is basically
what they call natural states natural
States are essentially organized as
patron client networks you have top men
if you will or elites who are militarily
potent and they arrange to have clients
to whom they distribute economic
resources they basically hand out
monopolies over time and the point here
is is that this was the basic
organization of human societies up until
two centuries ago when open access
orders began that rise that we know that
we saw in the chart from that johan
showed us earlier in in economic growth
the problem is is that and johann docum
very well in his in his book is that we
have been moving in the direction of
greater democracy greater freedom
greater openness over time using
particularly the data from Freedom House
but that have stalled lately the
question here is will it stall where we
have a reversal of that over time the
thing about natural states is is that as
patron client networks and that these if
you think about this and I would highly
recommend you that you do read this book
every state up until the beginning of
the 19th century essentially where was
organized this way it was the Roman
Empire the Incan Empire all the way up
to Putin's Russia or the Soviet Union
these were patron client networks and in
every case essentially those societies
ultimately stopped innovation and
stagnated so the question is can this be
stopped over time can we continue the
momentum forward to and up to more of an
access societies over time another
problem is the growth of the
surveillance society this is a map if
you will provided by privacy
international and published on the
wonderful website Cato unbound which
basically suggests you that for example
the United States is one of the worst
societies with regard to surveillance as
we now know Edward Snowden's through
Edward Snowden's revelations that this
is in fact a tremendous problem that we
have in this country the problem is is
that if you don't have privacy if you
don't have the space to to talk amongst
ourselves then progress and innovation
both in a social level can be stymied
and also we started with innovation that
basically what you will find is that
space where innovators can talk among
themselves out of the limelight will
will be reduced over time and and will
slow down progress again it would be
very hard to operate in that kind of
environment and it's not just my opinion
the privacy and civil liberties
oversight board which reported to
President Obama the following permitting
the government to routinely collect the
calling wreck
the entire nation fundamentally shifts
the balance of power between the state
and its citizens while the danger of
abuse may seem remote given historical
abuse of personal information by
government during the 20th century the
risk is more than merely theoretical and
it is more than merely theoretical we
still see people in Congress trying to
expand expand the surveillance state
United States earlier this year
Senator Dianne Feinstein and Senator
Richard burr introduced a bill they call
the compliance with court orders Act of
2016 well why shouldn't we apply comply
with court orders well the problem is is
that it basically says that web web
service providers technologists period
and telecommunications people must
provide backdoors to their technology so
that the government snoops can get in
whenever they want to the problem of
course is is that among many other
things is we can't be sure what the
government will do once they snoop with
that information and secondly bad guys
can also find those thing backdoors and
disrupt the economy and an innovation as
well I do suspect that if they even
thought about it a little bit that the
folks at the Democratic National
Committee wish they had used in to end
encryption but in any case now to what I
think is possibly the worst public
policy idea in all of history and this
includes communism the precautionary
principle which basically the proponents
say better safe than sorry we shouldn't
let any new technologies out until we've
proven that they're completely safe that
this is one way to do it I summarized it
as never do anything for the first time
one perfect example of this and and
there are lots of examples unfortunately
is the case of Golden Rice Golden Rice
is a biotech rice there's been developed
15 years ago more than 15 years ago that
it is enhanced by adding if you will
precursors to vitamin A it helps vitamin
A deficiency in countries that are rice
cultures if that is their basic food
and research has been trying to get this
to poor people in in Asia for a very
long time and has been stymied by
opposition by a lot of environmentalist
groups but none more than Greenpeace
which has been fighting this all the
time they have actually sent sent thugs
to International Rice Research Institute
to dig up the crops and and and kill
them off and that kind of thing the good
news is that in June 100 Nobel Prize
winners wrote an open letter to
Greenpeace excoriating them for this
campaign urging them to stop this
pointing out that by stymieing this
technology that World Health
Organization estimates that between a
core of a million of 500,000 kids go
blind every year because of vitamin A
deficiency in poor countries and that
half of these kids actually died within
a year or two after that because vitamin
A deficiency also means your immune
system is not as strong as it might be
to resist infections and the great news
is is that in this letter the nobilis
asserted a Greenpeace campaign bordered
on and I think they're being too nice
about bordering on a crime against
humanity this must be stopped but this
is just one example of how the
precautionary principle is deployed
across the globe and there are lots of
people who are in favor of this one of
my favorites of this is a by with us at
Yale University who wrote a book called
a dangerous master how to keep
technology from slipping beyond our
control window Wallach this author of
this book said is worried quote that our
incessant outpouring of ground breaking
discoveries and tools are raising a tech
storm that will soon be dangerously
beyond our control
the question of the harvest book is
whether quote we humanity as a whole
humanity as a whole have the
intelligence and again to navigate the
promise and perils of technological
innovation now how does he want to
navigate this in a precautionary manner
how does he want to do this well his
solution is to create this is his title
governance coordinating committees
that will guide policymakers in the
public the committees would be for
comprehensively coordinating the
development of different scientific
fields and oversee the industries that
each field creates so this would be
biotechnology artificial intelligence
nanotechnology robotics what-have-you
in other words they would function these
governance coordinating committees would
function as gatekeepers giving
permission or most likely not to the
rest of us to develop and use
technologies without apparent irony
Wallach writes and I quote moderating
the adoption of technology moderating
the adoption of technology should not be
done for ideological reasons is that the
idea of moderating progress is not
itself not ideological in any case those
are just some cautions that I do have
and worries about it I actually think
that the future that that the ten
reasons that are offered in yo.hannes
book are more likely to come through the
knot and I would like to once again and
restore your faith and the faith of the
rest of the public and in progress and
yo.hannes book would grow a great deal
in that direction and I heartily
heartily recommend it you can't buy too
many copies thank you very much thank
you very much Ron we now have some time
for Q&A I would like to ask you to
please raise your hand if you have a
question then when then wait for the mic
to get to you and if you could please
tell us who you are make the question
short in a form of a question and
address it to a - to a speaker yes right
hello hi I'm Tony Hong Kato intern a
quick question because I really like
your book financial Fiasco and
protection of capitalism and one of the
things I'm seeing and this is a question
I'm asking every people every person I
see that is for free market and free
trade is that since the market is
something invisible that people can see
it's difficult for a normal person to to
trust it it's a issue of trust however
it's easy to trust the government
because it's visible and they can hear
what the policy what their policies and
what their incentives are so what what
is a method that we could have to make
people trust something does it that is
invisible thank you thank you that's
that's a very good question and of
course that's the eternal problem in an
election campaign it seems like fewer
people are interested in the slogan
I don't know how America is going to be
great again but if I give all of you
more freedom to experiment with various
ideas I'm sure some of you will come up
with something some amazing technologies
and business models that will be
wonderful and I have no idea which ones
they are
they seem more interested in the kinds
of slogans that I'll make this happen
I'll do this trust me I'm the big tough
guy here I'll make people do that so
it's a problem of in a way how we
communicate this trust in in markets and
in individuals rather than specific
political forces on the other hand I
don't see that problem of trusting
people to everyday activities on the
contrary people do not have a problem in
going into a store and buying things
from people they've never seen and
eating it even though it might be
poisoned people just yeah I can go here
when I have to travel to another state
and city and just get a car from a
rental firm just by showing my piece of
plastic from Sweden and it's all fine
it's so perfect it works out in 99.9% of
all the cases
and people trust the market in that
regard and trust the rule of law it's
only when they make the shift into the
kind of political system the kind of
economic system that they like that they
for some reason forget their personal
experiences and the fact that they
dislike and do not trust the politicians
and that they are voting for again and
again and end up in this kind of
constant search for an authority figure
so that's an internal communications
problem and I think one of the most
important thing is to making people
understand their own personal trust in
the market and that that's something
that they should generalize into when
they're when they're voting as well I
actually don't have a solution to that
problem I wish I did why don't you work
on that and figure it out yeah what one
one of the the major concerns is they I
mean this is a problem that Basquiat
came up with with the you know the
visible and the the scene of the unseen
example whereas the policies are the
thing that we see whereas all the other
stuff that is that were is working for
us is exactly what you say it is
invisible it is unseen and you know I
would have everybody read Basquiat every
day as they're in a wake up prayer let's
start here in front yes I'll try to get
us nice robe rows my question is
directed to mr. Lee speak out a little
my question is directed to mr. norburg I
subscribed to the glass half full het
glass half empty you made some very
cogent arguments how things have
improved worldwide but I would turn the
question back on you in this country we
still have poverty and we still have
hunger and I asked you whether
Scandinavia has the same degree of
poverty and hunger and why shouldn't our
glass be fuller thank you
well I'm I'm Pro full glasses as full as
they they can get and the question is
really about well my own country Sweden
and and our neighboring countries and
well we have a generally a higher degree
of equality material equality than the
United States even though on a lower
material level than most other places
and I think all other things ceteris
paribus if it's the same thing we prefer
people not to be in poverty and not to
end up in difficult circumstances but
there is a difficult trade-off as well
and that one is we've done that by
increasing wages de-facto minimum wages
with because the trade unions are very
much in control of the labor market and
fairly generous welfare systems and that
means that I would it would be difficult
to find example of people in desperate
poverty in Sweden people who cannot make
ends meet so that there they cannot eat
on the other hand it also means that
many many of them are shut off from the
labour market entirely it means that
they are socially excluded from the rest
of society because they don't go up to a
job in the morning and that's something
that we realize right now because we
have a very large recent refugee
population in Sweden and we've created a
society that's very good if you have the
right level of education if you are very
productive you know the language and
everything then it's easy to get a job
and get a wage that's higher than the
welfare requirements and things like
that but if you don't you're priced out
of the market if you have a Productivity
level that's around 80 percent of
average well then you're priced out of
the market so we see a rise in
unemployment a rise in social exclusion
it does not mean desperate poverty it
does not mean hunger but it means a
terrible blow to self-esteem to status
in society gain in relation to your
neighbours and even your chil
and that results in a kind of not a
material desperation but a social
desperation that's really quite
problematic in in Sweden right now and
so so I'll just leave those facts on the
table and then we can all sort of decide
back and forth and the costs and
benefits of the various systems just one
thing I was a very puzzle because is we
know lots of people on the left site
Denmark and Scandinavia is a good
example of social mobility and equality
and so forth two other facts on the
table when I started looking into it
one is is that if you look at the Gini
coefficients that is the amount of the
degree of inequality from the lowest to
the highest if you look at the four for
example in Germany and France that
before taxes they're actually much
higher than the United States before
taxes
they're quite quite comparable in
Denmark and Scandinavia just a little
bit lower than those cases so the
Equality is achieved by taxing the rich
essentially the other side about it is
that everybody is going well social
mobility is greater well if you look at
the quintiles of populations I haven't
looked at these for Denmark the fact of
the matter is is that from getting to
the lowest quintile through the highest
quintile in Denmark you move from twenty
thousand dollars a year to about sixty
five thousand dollars a year in United
States since the journey of twenty
thousand dollars a year to a hundred and
sixty thousand dollars a year it's a lot
harder to get to a hundred sixty
thousand dollars a year but more
Americans do that but so the top is odd
it's a lot if you want social mobility
to go between quintiles go to Denmark
but you're not going to get a lot of
money out of that can I just add
something to complicate the picture even
further about Sweden and the other
scandinavian countries i sometimes meet
Bernie Sanders supporters who say that
the United States should be more like
Sweden on well let's pick Sweden because
it's where I come from and then I tell
them well in that case you have to have
more free trade than the United States
you have to have a more deregulated
market generally in more open product
markets you need to introduce
vultures so that people are entitled to
go to any kind of private school and and
keep the the money and and do that you
have to partially privatize the Social
Security system you have to abolish
property taxes and you have to abolish
death taxes and a couple of other things
when it comes to almost any area except
this thing with taxations and specific
labor market regulations Sweden and
Denmark are more economically free than
the United States so it is a very open
economy then it tries to redistribute
more of the results of of that and again
and I I just leave that at the table for
for everybody and including some of the
supporters a brief anecdote about that
he ran this Pro Scandinavian campaign
and at the same time was the the worst
protectionist since well since Donald
Trump I tell Bernie Sanders supporter an
anecdote about when President Obama
visited Sweden because then he was
approached by the three big labor unions
in Sweden and they are socialists
especially the big blue color one it's
very much affiliated with the Social
Democrats and they basically fund them
their message to President Obama was we
want to talk to you about an important
subject and that's free trade and why we
need more free trade between between
Europe and the United States because
that's the only way in which we can
constantly upgrade and restructure our
economy and give people better jobs and
higher wages in the future we think
you're too much of a protectionist
President Obama from the Swedish
socialists lastly I want to also comment
to your research by jonathan y from duke
university in a recent paper he found
that heritability of wealth is actually
higher in Europe than in the United
States roughly 12% of wealthy
individuals in the United States have
inherited their wealth in Denmark that
figure is 25% so roughly double of the
rate of the United States so I recommend
that research to you let's take a
question on this side gentleman in the
glasses over
Pat's pan I am was listening to mr.
Berg's presentation and follow on from
his ending quote from the from Star Trek
do you see the current system of the
nation-state as some sort of impediment
to the future progress or and means you
sound you sound like you're sort of a
one-world globalist there's the you see
the nation the concept of the
nation-state ie the United States as a
detriment detrimental thing yeah in
relation to the United Federation of
Planets right it's we're not there yet I
don't think that we should have a world
government I think that's a bad idea I
don't really care where the lines are
drawn but I think it's incredibly
important with some institutional
competition so that we have many
different political areas that have
different rules and institutions so that
we can see what works and what doesn't
and hopefully people will imitate the
ones that create more progress and more
human freedom and so I'm not in favor of
abolishing nation-states in that sense
but I am opposed to the kind of tariffs
the kind of walls that are being built
between countries so that people
citizens are banned or heavily regulated
when they want to engage in peaceful
capitalist acts between consenting
adults and basically trade exchange
movement those all those things which is
something that you can do even though
you have nation-states if they're open
to to individual freedom and economic
freedom yes
hi Edward Hudgens Peter Diamandis who
you know founded the XPrize and as well
as singularity University has a book
very much in the spirit of your
excellent book called abundance this
points to my question concerns the
audience for this kind of information we
have an audience of achievers of tech
folks of transhumanists of biohackers of
all of these sorts of folks who love
their work who are leading the progress
who want at least enough political
freedom and economic freedom to do what
they love doing yet they tend to be kind
of soft leftist because if they look at
the GOP they see Donald Trump and so on
and so forth
would this be a community that to answer
the question of how do we get around you
know the pessimism and all that you
could mobilize because one of the things
young people are excited about is
technology even though you have the the
pessimists that Ron pointed out quite
well I think that's a very good point
and one thing that you do see when it
comes to optimists versus pessimists is
that people who do things they are
normally optimists whereas those who do
not if they do not engage with
innovation with technology with new
markets and so on
they only tend to see the problems and
as Ron pointed out that the the problems
are often concentrated whereas the the
benefits often go to the whole of
society but if you feel like your driver
behind these events and those things
then you're more of a natural optimist
and you should be more in favor of more
freedom to do things like that and I
definitely think that that's a group
that should be mobilized more and I
don't know why that hasn't happened yet
Ron probably knows more of these people
than I do so perhaps he's got a better
response actually I'm not sure I do have
a better response but it's been a puzzle
to me as well
for example I cover and I've been
covering biotechnology for over thirty
years and a lot of biotechnologists
are weirdly inherently precautionary and
part of it stems from the fact that they
did not want to commit the same quote
crime that the physicists did with the
development of the atomic bomb so they
set up a system of precaution at the
silanol conference in the 1970s and has
fallen from there and it's and and the
truth is that when you talk to people
who are the real innovators as opposed
to academic academic biotechnologists
they're quite frustrated by the system
but it is it is set up that way now I
see it unravelling now one of the great
things is that the National Academy of
Sciences recently had a meeting to
discuss the amazing new CRISPR gene
editing technology and CRISPR by the way
if you haven't heard of it it's going to
completely change the world in ten years
and ways that you are not going to
recognize it's going to be amazing that
is if we can get the precautionary
people out of it but the great news is
is that the National Academy of Sciences
was asked to essentially ban using that
technology for use in human beings and
they said well actually no we need to go
slow but we're not going to be in favor
of a ban so I see some cracks in there
in that regard as well but it is a race
between the technologists and the
precautionary act of activism and I
don't know who's going to win that I'm
hoping that there'll be ten more good
reasons to before his future that's a
great sequel
Thomas Lam returned from Belgium and I
have a question for mr. norburg could
you speak up louder with regard to the
refugee situation some would call it
refugee crisis in Europe Angela Merkel
from Germany has said there chiffon does
and we can we can make it but let's
suppose that she would consult you and
say well I foolishly launched that
sentence but I forgot to develop the
arguments and now I have to address a
crowd of worried people very critical
people angry people and she needs you to
develop the arguments a one-pager a set
of arguments to call them down to put
things in perspective how would you
respond to that it would have to be a
very well paid position for me to accept
that I think because that would take
some really hard work off from other
things I think that the refugee crisis
and I think we should call it that
because a lot of countries were really
overwhelmed
last year in Europe by this influx from
Syria but also Afghanistan and several
other countries too an incredibly big
extent and at the same time we have
almost a planned economy in Europe when
it comes to any kind of reception in
accepting new refugees they're not
allowed to work they're not allowed to
start working it's a long Asylum process
in Sweden it could take two years until
you know whether you can stay or not
until then you're in a government
directed place where you where you sit
there all day and everything is heavily
regulated but I'll pay people who take
care of everything from cleaning to
preparing food which is a strange thing
which gives people the impression that
apparently if you're a refugee should
stop preparing your own food as well you
can't even clean your own house so
basically they're pacified in in so many
ways and they do not get the kind of
connection with societies that they need
in order to to be integrated what do I
tell Angela Merkel well first of all I
have to say that look the only thing
that could make the
work is that people are they get a basic
solidarity with the new societies that
they've come to and they only get that
if they are integrated by the labor
market if they start working if they
learn the language on the job if they
get new friends and neighbors whom they
interact with constantly and go to
school so that their their kids start
learning the language and get a taste
for the kind of culture that they that
they enter if that happens I think
there's a chance that they could be not
just well integrated but also very
useful productive members of society and
we've got a demographic situation in
Europe that's disastrous we have no way
of knowing how I will get any kind of
retirement to Social Security in the
future because there are too few workers
we have huge problems in the healthcare
sector many of low-skilled jobs that
where we don't have enough people they
should be able to fill this in
but the problem is we've got very high
minimum wages we've got very high taxes
it's incredibly expensive to hire anyone
to do anything and because it's all done
for very homogeneous imagina societies
where people have the same education
they have the same language they have a
lot of experience and so on then you can
enter the labour market but that means
that it's very easy to get your second
job but you never get your first job and
this is something that's difficult for
domestically born young people as well
we have very high youth unemployment as
well it's not just immigrants and
refugees so I would start telling Merkel
that we have to deal with that we have
to radically liberalize the labor market
we have to radically change the system
of taxation so that hope I don't
understand why we tax individual income
come at all we should find we should
reduce taxes but we should find out the
tax basis as well if I were to to deal
with this things so basically she opened
the external border for a while but she
forgot that there's another border
the labor market in around Society so
people end up in between and that's a
disaster that's a nightmare that's the
thing that creates social exclusion and
that's also what creates separation from
society and also some hatred against
this society that puts you in this
situation and attracts some people a few
people not even close to a majority to
radical Islamist ideas and that's
incredibly dangerous so if we open that
external border we have to open the
internal border as well so I think
unfortunately we have run out of time I
know there are many more questions but
both of our speakers are going to stick
around to sign books and to answer
questions and also please don't forget
that lunch is served
upstairs thank you very much for your
attendance and help me thank our
speakers today
[Applause]
here's a look at some upcoming book
fairs and festivals happening around the
country on Wednesday November 16th we're
in New York for the 2016 National Book
Awards then Friday November 18th it's
the National Press Club annual Book Fair
and authors night in Washington DC and
later this month will be live from the
Miami Book Fair on November 19th and
20th our coverage includes author
discussions and call-in programs
featuring senator Bernie Sanders Fox
News host Dana Perino and National Book
Award finalist Coulson white